it stands two two
between magnus carlsen and wesley so
after the second match this
means that we are moving on to blitz
and who will be the champion and who
will win
that remains to be seen so today we will
take a look at the first
blitz game between wesley and magnus
carlsen a very thrilling and exciting
game
absolutely great stuff
incredible stuff so let's take a look
e4 c6 from a magnus he once again goes
for car con
which is apparently an opening that you
had prepared
before before the match you also did
play this
in the first game out of the second
match as i
did already analyzed so everything is
the same here
d5 e5 bishop f5 knight knight of three
this time from westley so he changes
things up
he does not play the knight beat d2
knight f3 line this time he goes for
the more common knight of three bishop
e2 and castle setup which is
indeed a popular approach and certainly
not a dumb one black needs to be careful
there is a lot of
a theory let's see how the world
champion responded to this
so uh all right e6 bishop e2
once again we have this h6 move as i
have already mentioned in the other
video the point of this
is that we want to put the bishop on h7
so another idea here is to play a g5
as i also mentioned in the other video
where for example 97 knight g6
bishop e7 knight d7 also potentially
c5 you could even play c5 and knight c6
as
well a lot of different ways to go
white's plan
is different different he wants to play
on the king side with f4 g4 and perhaps
even f5 later
and go for an attack so let's see how
this went
castles 97.
wesley decides to take space with a4
i think that is certainly an interesting
way to go
magnus answers with a5 knight d2
knight d7 knight b3 so he once again
puts his knight on b3 he likes to have
his knight there
potentially play knight d4 and he also
gets some more cover on c5 very similar
to the previous game at this time just
one of the differences
is that magnus did not play bishop b4
here early he also did not play a queen
b6
so there are a few minor differences but
all in all it is
fairly fairly similar to we saw last
time especially after
the next moves here bishop h7 bishop d2
queen b6 already
it is slightly similar but
but it is different because there is no
c3 which means
that this knight is not really weak we
do not have to
have to protect that knight any longer
and not only that one important thing is
that we do have some attack against the
pawn on a5
which does mean that in the future i can
also put my
queen on e1 and then put even more
pressure on
on a5 i just got to make sure i protect
the c2 pawn
which is attacked by by the bishop here
h3
typical move that you make in order to
kind of wait to see what black does
because it's not that easy to find a
move
for black here c5 is not something you
want to do i can simply
simply take take take take and we should
be five and this is
very nice for for white for example
bishop e3 and knight d4
and the position black's position is
already
falling apart so something like that
would not be too great
one of the problems that black do have
is that he's simply not very developed
so he goes for knight g6 he wants to put
the bishop on e7 perhaps on b4
as well queen e1
and the only way to prevent the pawn
from being taken
is to play bishop b4 another thing you
should now keep in mind is that now that
the knight stands on g6
the pawn on c2 is no longer hanging so
queen e1 bishop b4
bishop takes queen takes queen takes a
takes let's
investigate further
bishop d3 by wesley he puts a bishop in
this
diagonal c5 as surprised i must admit
but magnus is counting on that he does
get enough play against the pawn and e5
so if i if i do take on c5 i can then
take on e5 and this is
very good for black very very solid
but i think he has underestimated a
little bit that i
can take with the knight here instead
which means knight x
g d takes then everything looks fine
doesn't it
after rook k5
but wesley has seen longer he has seen
longer and after bishop e5 check
king e7 rookie one we do want to put
more protection on
the pawn on e5 so rook c8
and everything seems fine have i now
been able to
to save myself i actually haven't
because wesley finds this great move c3
knight d4 is another it's not a good
move with the idea of knight b3
just throwing that out there it's c3
b takes c3 and here the brilliant move
b4
look at this great pawn chain right here
a4 b4 and c5
and now it's looking awfully lost for
the world champion with these pawns
marching down the board
it's not looking very great and he needs
to find a way to get counter play
against these pawns
because it will be too late this pawn is
going to fall
i can simply play roxy one and take it
and the bishop here is perfectly placed
protecting the pawn on a4
so this is not looking good for for
magnus
so rookie eight rooksy one attacking the
pawn
knight of four trying to to put some
counter play here
rook takes c3 bishop b4 remember that
this is a blitz game so
things went down incredibly fast a5
f6 trying to get more counter play
attacking at the center a little bit
h4 not so sure what the purpose of that
move is but i think wesley wants to play
g3 and get rid of that knight
remember that the rook on c3 protects
the knight on f3
so g5 magnus grabs some more space
g3 knight g6 things are going back in
warfare you can see that the evaluation
bar is jumping up and down
the position is completely winning for
wesley according to the computers
but this is blitz where everything can
happen and it's not so simple as it may
seem
the advantage is plus five which is
absolutely ridiculous
compared to the position we do have this
is by all means
not completely completely over e takes
f6
king takes f6 h takes g5 and this is
kind of an
inaccuracy you do not want to open up
the h file here
things could turn potentially slightly
dangerous so i'm gonna say that this is
a slight inaccuracy
it gives black a necessary counter play
counterplay that you do not want to give
black
so instead h5 would have been the way to
go and after something like knight of
fate you can then play
g4 just completely lock everything these
pawns are
very very strong and here black
is really struggling in order to find
good moves because my plan is knight d2
knight b3 knight d4
perhaps rook e3 as well to prevent e5
this knight is completely out of the
game black is completely helpless in
this game and
dead dead lost but after atex g5
8x35 knight h2 things
are not looking as good as they were
for wesley and that is understandable
you know time trouble blitz a lot of
things can happen
and things are getting more complicated
the best way to go would actually have
been to take the bishops
simply grab the bishop on e4 and then
play knight d2 pretend that nothing has
happened
i actually have so much play here that
it doesn't matter that i've
sacrificed an exchange i'm going to win
the pawn on e4
and i will be doing very very well due
to these amazing pawns in this great
bishop
this is uh like plus four for white
which is
kind of crazy but i will take and then
play knight d6 and
i haven't i have an overwhelming
advantage here
but wesley doesn't do it he plays knight
h2
and after 95 things are a lot more
complicated than they were just
two moves ago like after h5 there is no
counter play at all
remarkable isn't it so 95 rook
e3 my idea now is to play f3 but magnus
cc stat and it plays rook
h8 things are not easy any longer
there are a lot of complications here
and the
white kind of needs to be careful all of
a sudden there's tactics with
potential knight of three ideas or rook
takes h2 and a lot of things happening
here
so wesley plays f3 and as a matter of
fact this is a huge
mistake which puts the position
completely in balance here and magnus
once again spots the tactic rook takes
h2 king takes h to knight x f3 rook
takes f3 bishop takes f3
and things have now turned around
completely the position is now
balanced according to the engines it is
a complicated position where
everything can happen and magnus carson
has once again
pulled that houdini and turned things
around
when things were completely hopeless
but they're not any longer c6 from
wesley this is the principal approach is
now hoping for an inaccuracy by magnus
and will we get that in accuracy he
actually does get that in accuracy
after d4 which is a huge huge mistake
magnus carson here has managed to
balance things out but after d4
the position once again is lost for the
world uh for the world champion here
the the best way to go would have been
to take the pawn
bishop takes c6 and then simply play
rook a7
and apparently it is not easy to push
these pawns towards the goal here
if i do play something like rook f1 it
can always be met by g4
and this king is very active i can play
king e5 king d4 and it's not so easy to
to march with these pawns i also have
i have rook h7 rookie one ideas here as
well so maybe not rook f1 something like
king g1 makes sense to
not give rook h7 with a tempo but simply
bishop e4
king e5 king d6 marching with these
pawns is
very very difficult it will not lead
anywhere for wesley so and the position
is probably going to end in a draw
however there is a lot of play left
everything can happen but after
something like group game 1
rook h7 threatening rook h1 white needs
to move his rook
we have a perpetual after rook h1 king
f2 rook h2
and if i play something like king e3 i'm
almost mate after king e5
black black is winning and d4 are coming
so you're forced to go back
and that it's uh just a draw so kind of
crazy actually
and this is the way the game could have
continued
but magnus he misses his chance he
misses his chance with
with d4 i wonder what he did miss
because this is very very natural
but of course when yeah you are so low
on time
everything can happen things they go
they just go uh things go crazy crazy
stuff happens
and um that's what we saw here oops rook
h8
after rook f1 king j1 brook h1
king f2 rook takes f1 bishop takes f1
and i'm sure this is surely what he
didn't miss
because i'm sure he saw this well uh
i'm a genius because after rook f1 i
have rook h8 rook h1 and i can take here
and if i do take with the king i can
take the pawn b
pawn here and this end game is a draw
i'm sure that's what magnus
magnus thought and indeed that would
make some sense
but bishop takes f1 is a great move and
after bishop takes c6 to b5
bishop d7 white can simply play a6
b takes and again
magnus probably saw that after b6 he
could then play bishop c8
there is no problem whatsoever maybe
there's something even better i think
yeah bishop c8 is the only way to go
bishop g2 i suppose and then and then
this should also lead to
to a draw but
the simple b takes a6 is enough to get a
winning position
for wesley because the thing is you can
now play bishop g2
and you cannot stop this place a6 pawn
so d3 is the only way to go bishop takes
d3
king e5 but unfortunately for magnus
this end game here is completely losing
and this pawn
goes all the way
this means that wesley seoul did beat
magnus carson in the first blitch blitz
game
and magnus he had to win the second game
but unfortunately for him on his
birthday and all
it just uh he did manage to win and
wesley saw
is the champion of the skilling open he
wins the first tournament
of this of the second season of the
magnus carlsen
chess tour now the champions uh
chess tour and yeah
very impressive by wesley but of course
very impressive by magnus too he has
been playing well both of them have been
playing well what a thrilling match
an amazing match that's all i i can say
uh things they went crazy here
magnus got kind of outplayed i would say
this c5 move here was
very very bad it just didn't work out
at all and wesley's plan was brilliant
with c3 and then b4 later better move
would have been to maybe play a
b6 here something like that or maybe
simply castle
and the position is very good for for
white after something like a5 and rook
a4
it does look very pleasant for white but
i think
magnus would have to try something like
that and after
c5 in this sequence right here this is
simply very very very good for white and
after b4
white is completely winning things
changed and wesley did not play
accurately
and after 95 they tabled the tables they
did turn significantly
and here magnus had his only chance to
then play
b take c6 and then rook a7 even the
computer thinks that d4
is fine when you look at it first and
intuitively
it does look quite good but
unfortunately it turns out that the end
game sequence is simply lost for black
this would have been the only chance to
haul the game this is very likely to end
in a draw due to all of the counter play
against white's king and because of that
it is probably a draw but that didn't
happen
magnus carson made the last mistake
unfortunately for him
that was enough to to lose and
uh well congratulations to wesley cell
i hope that you've enjoyed my coverage
of uh the games of
the day from the skilling open you can
be make
you can be sure that i'll be back sooner
or
later so stay tuned for more great
content and as always
i'll see you soon